[Music]
[Applause]
tim kirchen he has forgotten more
baseball than i know espn major league
baseball reporter senior writer and he
has been named to the writer's wing of
the hall of fame
and uh as of 2022 career excellence
award winner inducted into cooperstown
this summer who would have thought that
tim would get in before barry bonds and
roger clemens
well i certainly didn't think that was
going to happen
i didn't think it would ever happen for
me but
i think this is going to be the largest
disparity in size between the player
that's elected and the writer that's
elected i weighed in at 1 40 this
morning dan so
giving up at least 140 to big poppy
and there's no steroid trace with you is
there time
well five four and a half 140 uh
and i can bench about 60. that i don't
think there's a possibility of steroids
no
if somebody didn't know the results of
yesterday how would you explain what
happened
well i would explain what happened
yesterday
well i hope i say this the right way
this is the most difficult process
the most difficult job that i've ever
had in 42 years of covering baseball is
trying to figure out
what to do with a ballot say like this
what do we do with bonds and clemens and
are they in a different category than
david ortiz and is he in a different
category than manny ramirez and alex
rodriguez those are the things that you
have to go through so i don't want any
sympathy neither do the writers we're
just saying this is a really difficult
process so somebody got in yesterday
david ortiz who i voted for and i
believe should be in the hall of fame on
the first ballot but the rest of it is
confusing and there are no more right
answers anymore dan i fill out my ballot
and i have for 31 years when i look at
my ballot these every time the last 10
years i look at and say well i didn't do
this right because there are no more
right answers it bothers me when people
would say to me or anyone else you did
it wrong i'm not sure you did it wrong
i'm just not sure you did it right
that's because there are so many
unanswered questions to all of this and
we need a little bit more clarity moving
forward
there are so many people who say the
following well bonds was a hall of famer
before
clemen's a hall of famer before
but i disagree i think if you're a hall
of famer you're a hall of famer and a
hall of famer wouldn't use steroids
performance-enhancing drugs bonds was
the best player in the game clemens had
a run with boston but then he went to
toronto like just trying to sort all of
this out like a-rod got popped twice big
poppy with the mitchell report i i don't
know what is hypocritical and what isn't
with this tim
yeah again dan this is what i run into
every single year for 10 years when we
vote and i'm not quite sure what to do
every year yes bonds was a hall of famer
before the late 90s with three mvps
clemens was a hall of famer before the
late 90s with three cy young awards and
yet my dear friend dan shaughnessy says
if you shoot 33 on the front nine and
you cheat on the back nine you're
disqualified for the round which is
essentially what you're saying i'm
saying
it's hard to argue with that and yet at
the same time this is baseball compared
to golf golfers
pga tour players call strokes on
themselves where baseball players were
encouraged during that bonds clements
time to do whatever it took to win
and there was this tacit agreement going
in major league baseball no one's
testing no one's checking you're going
to get away with this the other guys are
doing it so again this is where it leads
to all sorts of confusion but from 2005
on i see a little bit of clarity that we
were testing and checking from then on
alex rodriguez you know got popped twice
as you said so did manny ramirez i think
they're in a different category than
bonds and clemens but you can disagree
with me and i understand why it's just
really hard to try to put all this
together dan the easy way out is to just
say if you have a connection to peds
you're not getting my vote period yeah
the other easy way out is to say i don't
care what you did if you're one of the
10 best players on the ballot i'm going
to vote for you but i think there's
nuance to it and i think you have to
look at each case individually and
that's where it gets virtually
impossible to do this right and also
with curt schilling like i don't like
kurt the person with what he represents
or his tone
but i would put him in the hall of fame
i i just
i saw him perform on the biggest stages
um i didn't think he played for great
teams until he got to arizona and he was
a he was he wanted the ball he was a
gamer uh he was clean
but i don't know it likeability factors
in whether it's conscious or
subconscious here how do you explain
shilling not as a hall of famer
well like bonds and clemens and like
ortiz i voted for schilling every year
now some of the things he said and done
recently make me uncomfortable but i'm
voting on him
as a baseball player whose career has
ended 15 years ago and his political
views today are not going to sway me
from voting for him but again a lot of
people look at it differently and i
totally understand that he is not an
easy case either and he's not pedro
martinez randy johnson greg maddox great
he there is some borderline there but
when you look at the postseason you look
at the rest of numbers he's a hall of
famer for me i repeat i voted for him
every year
and but the character clause comes in
for certain players
i'm just not real comfortable being the
moral arbiter of all these things but we
have to be as voters these days
explain how clemens and or bonds get
into the hall of fame
well they could be
on the today's player ballot
in
committee uh in december i've been on
three of those committees dan it's a
fascinating process 16 guys in the room
media executives former players and if
one really powerful person in the room
can sway the argument that's how you can
get 12 out of 16 votes and get in the
hall of fame
my experience on these committees
is that the former players
and to a lesser degree the executives
are going to be harder on anyone with a
connection to peds than the writers are
so this thought that oh bonds and
clemens are going to go on this new
ballot in december which i think they
will and therefore they'll cruise
through as did you know jim codd and
tony oliva and
and alan trammell and jack morris and
harold baines in recent years
i just don't think it's going to go that
way because those guys don't have a
connection to peds so you better be
careful what you wish for going up
against the players who are in the hall
i'm not sure they're going to get their
vote i'm not sure but uh it's going to
be very interesting and we always talk
about well such and such didn't test
positive well sami sosa didn't i mean he
tested positive for a corked bat
why does it
why is sosa so far down the list
well that's a really good question dan
i think it's in part because he is a
symbol of the steroid era fairly or
unfairly and i had someone explain to me
i'd never thought about this if say he
had hit 50 homers three different times
instead of 60 homers
maybe he would get a lot more support
but i think people look at him
and say
who is the steroid era who's the number
one symbol i think some people
point at sami sosa if he wasn't so
dominant during those few years maybe he
would get more votes but bottom line is
he has a chance to go on that ballot in
december also
and it'll be really interesting how he
and schilling and bonds and clemens and
maybe others do if they're indeed on the
ballot
el touve is going to be interesting when
we get to that point but
you know he is the face of a cheating
scandal
nothing else attached to that but how do
we look at something like that as
opposed to peds
well that's a really good question
the way i look at it is if jose altuve
has hall of fame numbers when his career
is over
and i think he will
then
i would vote for jose altuve i think i'm
in the minority on that i think people
are going to look at this and say
well he cheated now are we certain that
he cheated are we certain that he was
taking the pitches and listening to the
bang of the the trash can i'm not
positive about that and without positive
proof and i'm still not sure if you know
what's coming that automatically you're
going to hit a home run surely it's
going to help but i think altuve is
going to be an interesting case when his
hall of fame
[Music]
possibility comes up but i repeat as of
now i would vote for him for the hall of
fame it's always great to talk to you
and uh congratulations again going into
cooperstown this is going to be sort of
like aaron judge and el tuve at second
base you and big papi standing up there
at cooper's you got to stand right next
to him right
well at some point i probably will but
let's be clear dan all kidding aside uh
the players are the players and the
writers are over here so if i stand
right next to him it's only a physical
thing
nothing more than that you get a plaque
or a bust
uh i think i get a plaque i'm not even
sure i think if i get a bust i'll be the
only one with a bus that's actual size
they can do your whole body like you're
not just your head
great great to talk to you tim thank you
buddy
okay dan see it that's tim kirkchen
what i love about tim and there's a lot
of things to love is that he he wants to
talk about the positives in the game
like he he cares about the game and
moving it forward